>>> GOERS HE
'RE BEGINNIN.
JO
SEIAN FORCESIS STRATEGIC
CRT CITY OF AB
0 PEOPLE NR THE BLK MAR CO
ADMINISTRATION.
U FOLEIR ORDERSD T COMING
IN SNGHE RUSSIAN
A WAR
ROHES FROM KYIIN.S VEISANFURTHE
>>> INEAN HIT S.RERT THEREARKIVN
SSLES.
THRIPUSH BACK RUSSIAN
MAYOR OMAMENTAG
ISY BEING T
THA
THIEYAND OUT
UT SAYS EYP
>> THER IS T
ELECTRICITY IN WHOLE CITY.
DO NOT HAVEER S
T HAVE SANITARSYSTEM,  DO NOT H.
CONTIESOR ONE DAY
WE HAVUOUS SR
26 HOURS THEY ARE YING OUR
TYM WEAPONS, FROTILLERY,RO
BOARDMENT, MULTIPLE LAUN
SO SITUATION IS  BRE DESTROYING.
M UAIVE FLEITAS
RECORDED MORE THAN 7N ES IN THE.
ATON THE
LO
IASTER SERGEY
D THEY ARETI TO  TION IN THE SE
OFSCOTT McLEAN IS IN
.RIUPOL VERY U SIEGE>> Reporte.
YOU CAN WATCH WHAT LIFE  LIK
THE
THAT CITY.
YRD FROTY6 HOURS OFS
SHELLING WATER, NO SEW THE NATUE
IT I GOOD IN
ROD CRKHEREN TO THE NS.
IT APPEARS THES
UKRAINIA A NO LONGER
THERE AND ARMED PEOP,
WORDS, CAM CITY
NISTRATI A
ADMINIP SIMILA NEW
OF EASTE UKRAINENGRGED .
E UKIA IS PLACE.ER FOR IT TO ST
WAY,EOPLE NEED TO FOLLOW
DIRECTIONS.
IT DOESN'T SEEM THEY AREWILLING.
WE HAVE SEEN NEW VIDEOSCEN NG TT
RUSSIAN SORS HAVE BEEN
PARKED "OutFrontOFNG.
A SILAR SITUATION IN THE S
TOWN OF KONOTOIN NORST
UKRAINE.
THAT IS WHERE PEOPLE HAVE BEENG
IN FRONT OF TANKS.T AN
UNDETA RUSSIANS O ONE WILL SHOO.
THL STN
PLACE.
BUT AL RUSSIAN
OUTY THAT WILLIN PLA THEE
BEING.
PRESIDENT LESAID
HUMANIS IN TO HE COMING IN FROM
FOREIGN ALLIES ABROAD.
ANT  TO TALK A
LEITBOUT THE
REFUGEE SITUATHEN LVIV.
I WAS AT THE TRAINTATION
YESTERDAY WHER AREG INAOTIC TH
THEY HAVE EN
IS TAKING PRESSURF THE
F PE IS
HEE AI'S A MAN AAME
TO SEE OFF HIS WIFE
SPEND THE LAST FEW HOUALL THY,
THEM.
IT WAS AMAZING TO SEEMOTL  OGOOH
THAT MAN IS GOG  ENLIST INTH
JO THEINT SO MANNG AN K
T
MOINTHA
POWERFUL SITUATION A
CNN'S ALEX MARQUARDT WITTH
LATEST ON THIG
UKRAINIAN CAPITAter: YEAH, JOHN.
GTISTOP REPORTS
OF ATTACKSND
FROM ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IOUNDED ON
THREE SIDES.EYESN THPI
RUSSIAN FORCESM TOE
IT ANDGOVERN
.
THE BLAS
REWEON WEDNESDAY EVENINGNEAR THI
GET TO SAFETY, WHAT SCOTT Y AND
, HEADING
WEST TOWARDS HIM IIVBLASDAMAGEAM
THE RAILY STATION.IT ALSO, VERRA
PIPELINE.LEAR WHAT
WAS.
E OR MINISY HERE
BELIEVEST A N CRUISE
MISSILINTERCEPTED BY THEIR
T .
BUN ABOUT WHAT THE RUSSIANS MA
ANOU KYIV, WHETHER THEY
MIGHBE HTI, E Y GRIDRSE.
AND SSIANSMSELVES
DO P HIT COMMUNICATIONINFRASTRU
INFOIOCKS ON R
THEY KNOW THEY AREE
NARRE, THAT TH AG  INFORMATION R
U  SPEAKG TEF A RUSSIAN STRIKE
MILES  TR.
WE ECK
L DE
NOORD OF KPHARBLTSET.
ISEEN.
LLONS.N F
COMINTOWARDS IVTO COMSS FROM WS
INVASION. C
T 20 MILES, 30
KILOMETERS NORTH OF THE CITY.
BRD ER OFFIC
STALLED.
IT HAS COME TO A STODE  SIGNIFI.
NUMBER OF  ARE HAVING , THEYVI
TROOPS.
IS UKRAINIAN
WE HAVE SECETTS ELSEWHERAR
KYTIME THEY
BELIEVE TH REGROUPI, REASSESSAN
PERHAPOTTING T